各位小伙伴分享一个基于我们
OpenAI GPT Image 2接口的一个图片生成一遍及工具
那么给大家看一下我们的一个效果
这个呢是搭建完毕之后的
我们可以呢直接生成啊
GPT2生成的一个图片
我们可以看到这个呢是简单的一个大海
然后呢我这呢是让它制作一张啊
冰临动物的一个视觉丰富心图
我们可以看到这呢生成之后呢
是完全完全的非常非常的一个清晰啊
而且呢这个呢完全就和我们在XGPT上生成的是基本上是一致的
那么它的核心原理呢就是我们可以通过自己搭建
来提供我们XGPT的一个API key
或者说呢我们通过CPA的形式将我们自己账号呢
返代到我们的一个CPA上去
我们可以通过这个网
返代之后呢我们就可以通过CPA的这个地址
IPI地址呢配置到我们这里面
我们就可以使用到我们这些拆的GPT2的这个图像了
我们就不用限制在
必须在拆的GPT的客户端里面
或者我能够的Codex等的客户端里面
这样来呢
我们可以在其他地方使用更方便
好
那么接下来呢
我们真实的去看一下这个项目
这个项目呢
叫做GPT Image-Plate Ground
那么这里呢
我们可以看到
首先它的网站这里
也给大家提供了一个在线端的一个配置前段界面
它这个呢
没有任何的配置
需要你自己进行一个配置
如果说你不想自己搭建呢
你可以用它这个
那么今天呢
我肯定是要带大家来
执行一下搭建的步骤的
那么你不想执行搭建呢
你就直接使用它
首页这个就可以了
那么这呢
我再给大家讲解一下
它的基本配置
这里呢
如果说你使用
你有自己的
OpenAI官方的Key呢
你这里可以直接不用改
这里呢
换成OpenAIKey就可以了
然后这里呢
API接口我们看了
它有一个V1的image
还有我们的一个response的
那么一般来说我们用remer response的
response呢
它是基于我们的一个VR的
我们这里的模型呢
现在来说最新的都是支持我们的一个5.5的啊
它每个高级模型
它都是有一个image
刚刚generation的一个tools攻击类的
它其实是这个模型呢
会去掉这个攻击类
从而去生成模型
这样去配置的
那么它这里呢还有一个code sdr这code sdr呢这里会有一个基本的一个说明我给大家看一下好关于这里呢我可以看到这里呢
再给大家说一下
它支持呢
V1啊
还有我们Response
对不对
刚才想给大家讲解一下
就是我们一个Codex CR兼入模式
那这个呢
是我们可以在设计中开启这个模式
也就是这个模式
可以打开它
那么这个模式呢
开启后呢
它会根据于我们在Codex的
相当于说
我们在Codex的命令行中
实际的可用能力将质量参数固定为Auto
且不会发送我们一个quality一个字段
所以说这Emerly UI
它会多图拆分成多个并发完成
那么一般来说这个可开可不开
你可以基本上不用开
也都是可以的
那么将你配置完毕之后
我们就可以进行一个爽用了
那么下面我们可以看到
它有这么一个配置
什么Auto
Auto这里有一个尺寸
比如说我们可以按比例
还有分辨率
1K 2K 4K
然后图像比例
比如说21比9啊
16比9啊
然后自定义
还可以自定义一个宽高
也就是说呢
我们要自定义宽高
但自定义宽高这里说的很清楚
必须为16的倍数
也就是说呢
最大的边长是3840
而宽高呢
不能超过3比1
就这么一个限制
还有呢
我们的质量啊
质量呢
是有几档
4档
Auto
Low
Middle
High
然后呢
格式
支持我们的一个GPG
还有YPG
都是支持的
亚素率这
然后图片最多呢支持生成多个
图片在这里最多最多支持我们的一个
参考图呢支持16张
那么最多这里呢图片最多40多张
到这里没有说啊
那这里呢应该也是有一个
大家就按照16张这么一个来测试吧
不要生成的一个太多
可能会导致你这个
一下启用过多呢会触发一些风控啊
目前来说应该是没有的
好那么这呢就给大家
接下来呢就给大家看一下怎么去搭建
这个呢是我搭建好之后啊
生成的这么一个很简单
那么我推荐大家呢
使用我们的一个下面这个啊
而这来搭建
那因为我们使用它呢
我们直接一键就可以了
真的很简单
一键啊
我就不需要再去点了
直接点这个
因为我这已经有一个存在的这么一个仓库了
直接点create就可以了
其他的就不用管
你这里的时候呢
可能需要你进行一个gethub账号
一个登陆
你就直接登陆你的gethub账号就可以了等了完毕之后呢你再点这个 display 一键一键部署然后这个 responnse name呢你想改可改可不改如果你不改呢它的前面的生成的自定义的UR呢
就叫做gpt image
Playground
然后呢
-smoke什么什么
这些是自定义的
但前面这几个是根据你
当前的项目的
也是说它这个项目的
就是根据你仓库的名字
来定义你这个UR前缀了
大家呢
记得这个要去
自己想改改
不想改不改
改了之后呢
你在这里请求用来的时候
它就会变成你改的名字
然后直接点击create就可以了
然后等一会儿
什么都不用做
过一会儿之后就可以了
过一会儿之后
你就会进到我这么一个的
这一个界面了
那么进到这边之后
刚才给大家说了
对吧
那这里给大家看一下
我的一个配置
配置这里呢
我使用的是
我自己搭建的一个CP
也就是我们的一个CP代理
那么CP代理呢
我们可以使用它来进行一个
Also Download
也就是说我们可以
代理很多
比如说你使用的拆GPT
我们就可以使用CodeX
Auto的方式进行登录授权
那么相当于说进行一个反代
那么这样来我就可以多账号一个聚合
我可以看到我这呢就是一个多账号的聚合
刚才我测试一下就走的GPT5
然后这下面的APIK
就是你在这CPA里面配置的APIK
那么接口呢刚刚给大家说了
你这里呢可以用V1的版本
对吧模型呢就用GPT5.5
我们现在最新版
最新的模型5.5呢
哎已经出来了
那么当你比如说你这里呢
可以生成你描述需要生成的图
对吧
我比如说
一个女孩
在
海上游泳
你这直接描述你的提示词
然后呢尺寸呢
我这里比如说呢
我想按照一个生成一个16比9的
2K的对吧
我们点确定
然后呢图片呢
我们选择就选择一剂
然后数量呢
我选择一个
当然那这里呢
你还可以上传你的参考图
你直接点击上传参考图
就会说以你这个参考图来生成
那么比如说我直接点击发送
就可以了
它这里呢就会这么一个等待创战
可以看到我这里的生成尺寸呢
是一个16比9的一个尺寸
我选择的是一个16比9的
2K的16比9的这么大一个尺寸
它就会生成一个
然后质量呢我选择的是auto的模式
这里都会显示
当你这请求之后呢
其实你在后台这里
你就可以看到你这里有个请求
我们刷新一下
等一下
好我们看到这里呢就有已经发送了一支请求了啊这里已经打到你的后台了那么其实在配置这里的时候再给大家塑下有个坑如果说你是跟我一样
适应我们的一个普通的HTT方式去配置的话
那么现在的高端
我们的Chrome连线会拦截
也就是说
由于我们这里
它给你Waterway生成的链接
它是HTPS的
那么你HTPS里面就有访问
HTP自然请求
它是禁止不允许的
那么这个怎么办呢
这个两种方式
第一种呢
我们自己去搭建域名
然后通过域名的方式
就是我们Cloud Flavor
去进行一个配置
然后进行访问
那么还有一种方式呢
就是我们可以在浏览器面设置
那么今天呢
给大家教个简单的
我们在浏览器里面如何设置啊
然后浏览器里面打开你的一个设置
这里有个设置
设置之后呢
我们点击到隐私以安全
我们的一个看一下
有一个不安全内容
我们点击不安全内容
我们看到这个呢
我已经添加了
那么这个呢
就是你需要设置点的
你要允许显示不安全的内容
那么点击添加
这个时候呢
你添加你的网站
我这呢
你就添加你自己到时候生成这个域名网站
就是你要添加了生成之后
这个域名的网站信息
那么将它添加进来
那么添加了之后呢
你这个时候再去按照我当前这种配置
就说你这里可以不配置我们的HDP
就HTPS的
就普通的HTP呢
这时候呢
我们也可以正常一个访问了
我们可以看到
这个呢就是我生成的
对吧
一个女孩
她在一个大海里游泳
非常漂亮
我们可以看到
非常非常的
beautiful
还是非常不错的
可以看到
高清的
拼音机的
看到没有
那就生成了
那么我们生成完毕之后呢
我们当然呢
也可以进行一个
直接不想要了
我们直接进行一个
删除就可以了
它这个呢
完全是存储在你本地的浏览器的
这个没有存储在后台上去的
就是如果说你换个浏览器
或者说你开启我们的一个无痕模式的情况下
你相当于说进一个完全崭新的
那你换个用户账户呢
也是一样的
这个完全存储在你本地的浏览器的local style里面存储的
这个很安全
大家可以放心
好
那么今天呢
就简单给各位小伙伴分享一下
我们的一个非常不错的GPT
Emmage 2的接口的图片生成一个变迹工具
好
如果大家有什么疑问呢
欢迎来到视频下方给我留言